[Music]  it's clear Angela Bassett has still got  her group I was like oh my god really  are you kidding me no we are not joking  Angela turned 60 on Thursday and she  looks ageless the mission impossible  fallout star took to social media  sharing this makeup free pic showing off  her toned arms and abs in a graphic  printed bikini Angela caption the sexy  beat a snap quote happy birthday to all  my leo brothers and sisters let's eat  cake  while the actress has said cake is her  guilty pleasure  she told et her healthy lifestyle is  what keeps her fit if we get up and move  you know propel us forward we began to  feel better and isn't it true that after  a good workout you never say oh I wish I  hadn't done that and we see why Angela  has no regrets hitting the gym with a  physique like that  [Music]  [Applause]